and of this
[Music] there
are so many
this is a western
interest his way doctor edwin leonard
bernstein ends forecast report of
the class center in the third miner
this time I am going to put
different actions in you in your life also
annul this former professional 3
transformers only  that you can have on your
big page on facebook
for the good of all
[Music] it
's a fanning reality you can see how
difficult it is for
atheist people and how are
you you know it's a 3 cat
remember that I'm not very much of this
time or modern anymore and  also be in my
world is half closed also
ask me about making molds the tips
of the chili peppers
in my world you upload photos to facebook
because you don't upload boots because I don't have much
interesting to put up as one grows up
you think it will lower self-esteem if it
happens but one  it's like a continuous struggle
and if you see one then obviously
getting older like sometimes that to
people as used I don't look so
good anymore and like you want that not like that
account one has to have a
young spirit not how you look but how you
feel that is what matters and
enjoy life if
nothing hurts you and that is not gain and you have
to enjoy
the destiny of others
[Music]
Yes,
this photo is going to be there,
my photos, and since I don't have a photo, she
likes to have it and some more like a
silhouette, I don't have photos, that is, I think I'm
daughters,
we're going to take the photo and then this
photo has to change its photo  in profile
[Music]
what is your favorite pose to do when
they take pictures of you something like well I like
how three quarters is three quarters like this
[Music]
and this is a gigantic laugh
ah
[Music]
and before glass and hardware and john clemens
fritz in winners ruby rooms the t
o avn failures how v
ry
eautiful very original how it felt
hen they are taking the photos it is very
mportant very excited even more peopl
artists i was surprised to see that appen
age of super unique or am i still expir
d  By e  The case because of course they are not the
photos of my 30s because I am not so
young anymore but I feel very
young in spirit that is what matters and if you have
to take photos especially to
leave my children to my grandchildren of shakespeare
insmet  levels of achievement in the derby
difficulty times' and 'the is negative he is
no longer
algiers face with graphically they are
links of this in my journey to his mind
commit transvestite who is the lived of
various forums
[Music]